hey guys it is Friday which means not
gonna dig into some of the biggest
stories of this week and let you know
what we think about them and encourage
you to let us know what you think about
those well in that comment section one
sentence let's get started welcome PC
brethren to the world of destiny - it's
kind of just our world except there's
like space magic and stuff but in the
latest faction rally that's just come
out for destiny - Bungie has made some
changes as to how faction tokens are
made so in the are in the first faction
rally you were able to go into a lost
sector and you had to destroy resources
and that was how you got tokens to then
go and buy cool guns and shaders and
armor and all that kind of stuff now
because there was an exploit in the
first one where you could run the same
lost sector over and over and get tokens
quite easily they changed it so now you
have to you can the only way to get
tokens at the end is to open the the
chests that are at the end of a lost
second which is basically just like a
dungeon is it basically a new loot cave
in the winding cove on earth where if
you go in and run the lost sector you
can get to the end you can open them
open their chest after you destroy the
boss they can just walk outside go until
you get the winding cone flavor text to
go back in no enemies a respawn and you
can open that chest again and you can
just get faction token after faction
token so if you are playing destiny I'm
not I have been too busy but seen all
the games come out my movements done
I've been busy playing all that stuff
but it looks like you can now get your
hands on it and it'll zuv faction tokens
have a scrooge mcduck Ian bolt-action
typing it is worth mentioning this
exploit was found a couple of days ago
we're not a hundred percent sure if it's
still working but uh let your friends
know down in the comment section and if
you want to use exploits ok whether or
not you're a fan of them it's hard to
not say that microtransactions are
definitely working at least for the
triple-a publishers who are using them
one of which is take two who came out
this week to say that they won't
necessarily have microtransactions in
every game but they are gonna have some
kind of ongoing payment model with every
game they bring out from now on so that
means there's gonna be some way to keep
financially engaging in the games
they're bringing out and yes that
includes Red Dead Redemption - oh I
could I can feel feel the the bristling
of everybody through the internet just
then yes but of course with the success
GTA online that's to be expected and
this is something that takes you haven't
shied away from they've said that you
know there's definitely gonna be micro
transactions in Red Dead Redemption to
online in some way they've already said
that that's gonna happen but this is
more of a it's it's come out at a very
inopportune time I think to be
discussing micro transactions yeah I
mean it's interesting because there is
so much controversy which you think
would weigh on them not wanting to do
micro transactions but at the same time
what everyone has to understand from
their perspective whether we like it or
not which a lot of us don't
is that a take to revealed that 42
percent of their net bookings for the
last quarter came from micro
transactions and I also that's revenue
let me let me let me play devil's
advocate here I will go as far as to say
GTA online is one of the only games
where I would say the micro transactions
honestly don't really impact me as
someone who doesn't buy them that much
yeah because you're buying sharp
cartridges which you can then use to buy
you know cards planes
property all that kind of stuff but if
you just have GTA online you can still
get access to all of that all of the
gameplay to tear all that one thing out
audience likes it's playing devil's
advocate they do micro transactions but
I think what everyone's really worried
about as well is if micro transactions
are gonna arrive in the single-player of
Red Dead we've been a really big a big
trend at the moment I really do think
that a wide eye I'm too I'm too
optimistic come on
Rockstar prove me right just what would
I get if I got a ps2 in a ps3 I just jam
together you get a ps2 point three wait
five I drop math PS five that's right
and speaking of PS five and Xbox two one
one who knows edmo the CEO of Ubisoft
has discussed the next generation of
consoles in earnings call he said it's
at least two years away and then he very
quickly put in some caveats he was like
hey hey we don't have any confidential
information well I'm just I'm just
spitballing here you know what I
honestly believe they don't have any
confidential information I just think
they are they're dropping that in there
because it's it's relevant to make sure
that current gaming audience knows that
their consoles are gonna be relevant
a long time especially with the new
iterative consoles which of course you
can play the same games across its kind
of supporting what we've already got now
but if people want that bump they can
get that bump if they can you know want
to put in the money for it but yeah I
think it's quite realistic to expect
them to be at least two years off the
next generation if not more hmm
absolutely because the last console
generation was one of the longest
generations ever so that's something
that I think a lot of a lot of our
audience who grew up when that was kind
of their first big video game console I
remember when it was like ps1 was that
like four years and the ps2 came out now
is out for like four years and all of a
sudden the ps3 came out and it stuck
around for like most of my 20s so you
know it's it's it's interesting so I
really enjoy the idea of longer console
generations with iterative upgrades I
think that's a really cool idea and I
hope that that's something that we see
from the PS 5 or the Xbox 2 we need a
better name the Xbox I think what we
need to do is push that way into a
future to use we'll get back to you that
is everything we happy this week dude
let us know what you thought about
today's stories or any of this week's
stories down in that comment books and
be sure to have a good weekend because
we're not gonna see you till Monday what
I'm gonna see you Monday and don't
forget next week is the time when game
Scott's game Scott's game spots gonna be
doing extra life yeah so please tune in
next weekend 72 hours of video games all
for the children so much is the lack of
sleep and so many pixels in our balls
I've gone blind I've gone blind from so
many so many games
[Music]